A key concept in this course,
we'll be lifecycle.
So these are the different lifecycle
stages, material extraction,
material processing, manufacturing use,
and we'll call it waste management.
Ideally, we'll, we'll talk about ways
of, we're not talking about end of life,
but rather closing loops.
Why is life cycle thinking going
to be absolutely essential to, uh,
uh, green chemistry discussion
as sustainability discussion?
Let's go through it. Uh, so,
oh, when we look at the
origins of our feedstocks,
it would be very possible to
produce a product that is nontoxic,
affective, performs great. You
know, a little kid could chew on it,
no problem,
but yet do it in a way that results
in dramatic ecological damage.
But you might say that that's a,
that's a rarity right now.
That's pretty much the little,
the rule of the road.
What did we say about the amount
of, uh, uh, of waste generated per,
uh, per pound of product
for manufacturing generally?
Yeah,
so we're talking about 90% of all of the
material that goes into manufacturing
winds up immediately. His waste. And
it's the character, not the amount,
the character, the nature of the
inherent nature of those materials.
That is crucial. Important. Is
it to pleading? Is it renewable?
Is it inherently toxic?
All right,
so we know what manufacturing is, is a
conversion of raw materials into products.
It's like in the design and
the production of goods and
manufacturing needs to add value in
order for it to be really considered
manufacturing.
Although there are a lot of businesses
that it's very questionable. Um,
so is manufacturing important?
These are the different industry sectors
and this is the a billion tons of waste.
Waste generated manufacturing waste
are significant to say the least.
When you take a look at the annual
waste generator, this is a EU data. Uh,
uh, manufacturing wastes
are, are significant,
but these other, uh, Eric,
now a quicker side energy production,
very little waste,
1%. What does that mean? It means,
and we'll talk about this,
that the petrochemical industry is
one of the most materially efficient
industries that the world has ever seen.
Almost.
If you only got a 99% efficiency for
many of the petrochemical processes,
you'd be fired. You'd be shut
down. It'd be out of business.
The degree to which they are
so excellent at efficiency,
we can say, oh, well good then
that, then that's perfect.
That's why we talk about life cycle,
because it's not all about efficiency.
It's not all about one life cycle stage.
Okay. What about the use
phase? They say, Oh, I'm,
I meet a washing machine
and I made it from a,
from a new Birol renewable resin and I,
and I'm going to recycle the whole thing.
Where's the impact?
Was the environmental impact,
uh, of a, of a washing machine.
It's in the use phase,
the energy consumed in the use and the
water consumed in the US, et Cetera,
et cetera. Uh, what about, um,
is important.
Think about those products
where they use is of necessity.
Dissipative remember I laws of
thermodynamics chlorofluorocarbons,
whether it's in sprays or, or
whatever it is, propellant.
These lined up in the ozone layer.
Solvents,
wide range of solvents are
amongst the highest, uh,
emissions, air emission, uh,
chemicals known coolin's.
Pesticides and fertilizers necessarily
have to be distributed in the environment
to function.
It's why they wind up in our groundwater.
It's why they wind up in our drinking
water. Okay. Is End of life important?
Yeah. It kind of speaks
for itself, I guess. Yeah.
That's the base camp of the handle.
A's. But you want to go for a track?
All right.
Okay.
So we need to have lifecycle thinking.
This is not a life cycle analysis class.
We're not going to do a rigorous
lifecycle analysis, lagers,
rigorous lifecycle assessment. However,
if we don't think across lifecycle,
then we will do exactly the wrong things
by shifting the problem from one life.
So Lycos lifecycle stage to another,
and you will know where to find them.
That is so often the
essence of greenwashing.